hey what's up my name's samuel leeds i'm
a property investor and right now
i'm gonna be answering your property
investment questions if you're wanting
to become financially free
through property there's some things you
really just need to know
and a lot of people ask me the same
questions over and over and over again
so i thought why not answer all of your
common questions
here on youtube so if you've got a
question for me
comment it below in the comment box and
i'll do my very best to answer your
questions
also please do me a favor as i go
through answering these questions
please hit the like button also
subscribe to the channel so you don't
miss a future video right let's see what
we got
silver ltc what's happening silver ltc
he says
i'm in the process of buying a three bed
house but the attic room
hasn't been signed off
as such is it legally a two-bedroom
should i renegotiate or bail thanks
samuel god bless
okay if you're buying a three bed
but the attic room hasn't been signed
off so there's two rooms
you can't class the attic room as a
bedroom because if it's not been signed
off by building controls or by the
council
it isn't a room it's loft space
can it be used as a room maybe but it
isn't
so i would 100 renegotiate also just
make sure
um when you're buying it your mortgage
lender is happy
also your insurance company is happy i'm
not saying for a minute that
if it hasn't had building control or
planning permission to convert the loft
oh my gosh don't buy it
but just remember it's not a two bed
house sorry it's not a three bed house
it's a two bed house
with loft space and you know the agent
really should not be advertising it as a
three bed
um so i would renegotiate wouldn't
necessarily bail
i would renegotiate the price based on a
two bed
and i would also make sure that there's
no issues with your insurers or lenders
that helps mjl says i'm 17.
what would you recommend for me to do
save
and would house flipping be a good
option listen
saving money i don't believe in saving
money i believe in storing money now the
difference between saving money and
storing money
saving money is when you just save it
for a rainy day or you just put it away
and you save it up in the bank you lock
it away in the bank
that's not smart because money is
shrinking storing
money is when you store it with a view
to
invest it so i would i would get 100 i
would save money or store money
and house flipping would that be a good
option maybe
i mean if you're 17 i would be more
inclined to just try and get yourself
on the ladder on the ladder get your
foot in the door
if you buy a house and sell it it's a
lot of work and then you lose the house
and the profit that you get you have to
pay tax on
so you're probably better off buying it
pushing it up and instead of selling it
refinancing it and then any money that
you pull out is
tax free and you keep the house
which means you've got a house to your
portfolio that you can rent
so i'll probably do that but anyway good
luck
okay miles some firm says
i wanted to know how you work out the
occupation rate
in an area when doing rent to serviced
accommodation
right so if you're doing rent-to-service
accommodation
first thing i'll say is across the
country
you're talking about 75 to 85 percent
occupancy rate is about standard
so if you're renting a property out of
serviced accommodation
namely short staylets on booking.com and
airbnb
you're probably if it's a nice decent
house
you're probably going to be it's
probably going to be void about 20
of the time so that's just standard
however
what i would suggest that you do is look
on booking.com
and see how full the hotels are if you
can't book a hotel within the next three
days because everywhere's fully booked
and your property is in that area that's
a really good sign
if you're ringing up or ring up a hotel
and say hi i'm looking for um
a stay with myself and some of my we're
gonna work party we're looking for six
rooms
is that gonna be possible i know it's
short notice and if they go yep that's
fine
that's a bad sign um a good sign is when
they're fully booked up
go on airbnb and on airbnb you can
actually look at not only the prices of
your competitors room rates
but you can see their calendar and you
can see how filled up they are
for the next six months ahead so that
will give you an
idea there's also websites you can go on
like air dna
air d and a where they'll give you an
average occupancy rate in the area
but ultimately if you do rent a serviced
accommodation calculate
worst case scenario and need to make 500
pounds a month
profit and then if it's even worse than
that
you're still making a little bit of
profit be conservative you're never
going to know the exact
occupancy rate because until you do it
and every month and every year will
differ anyway so that's probably my best
advice i can say right now i hope that
helps
by the way if i answer a question and
then you have another question that
shoots in your brain as i'm answering
your question
comment your question below i'll do my
best to answer as many questions as i
can comment comment comment don't forget
as well to hit the like button if you
find this helpful
sharna samson hi samuel great video i'm
looking to get into lease options i'm
just thinking if i
stack up say five lease option deals for
five years time
then the time comes to purchase how will
the mortgage lenders look at this
would they not reject me because of too
many mortgages being acquired and maybe
not high enough income
um shana one of the reasons people do
lease option agreements is because they
haven't got the money but the second
reason is because they haven't got the
credit
so if you do a lease option agreement
and you know in five years time
you've got five years to buy these
houses that gives you five years
to get your mortgaging principles
approved your credit sorted
um if you've got a lease option
agreement
there are that you are going to need to
qualify for a mortgage usually how you
structure it is you'll buy it
for cash with a bridging loan and then
you'll then refinance because a lot of
lenders won't want to lend to you
at the end of a lease option because
they'll say you've got an interest in
this property already and you have for
five years
so so my my advice would be don't even
worry about it because you don't have to
buy it anyway
right now just walk the abc you're
trying to work out what
in five years time what was if i've got
too many lease options
that's a really good problem to have go
and get one lease option agreement right
now and then let's book a call and we
can have a chat but
your question is very valid but that's
not your problem right now
your problem right now is getting the
deals so i could spend 20 minutes
talking about
how to structure it in five years time
but you haven't got the deals right now
does that make sense
um all right next page ingram i have a
compliant deal packaging company and i
want to work with kodi or sources are
there any contracts needed for this
between me and the deal sourcer
yes always have a contract
if you're doing business with anybody
whether that be an investor
a builder whether that be a deal sourcer
kodi or sourcing
whatever it is have a written
contract do you need a 27-page contract
written
by the top lawyers in london no
you can just have a basic one-page
contract with an understanding of what
your agreement is
and generally speaking if it's a simple
agreement
that will be enough to stand up in court
but yeah if you're doing code your
source and have an agreement otherwise
you could give a deal to a deal source
and they could sell it and they could
say
oh actually we changed our mind we don't
want to give you any money
you need a written agreement jake
sansby i've been following you for a
while over the content me and my partner
are attending your crash course
um if we're looking to become deal
sources and only deal sources
would you advise against starting a
limited company due to accounting fees
needed each year
as well as other annual fees um
no i wouldn't if you're wanting to start
a deal sourcing company number one a
limited company is going to give you
the company is going to be protected so
it gives you limited liability
which means if someone tries to sue you
hey you sold me a deal i don't like that
deal
and now i've lost money and they go
after you they're not going after you
they're going after your company which
has got a
ring fence around it so worst case
if they sued your company and they won
and they sued your company for a million
pounds your company would then
fold but you would be would be protected
so really important they have a limited
company for deal sourcing
from a cost perspective yeah you might
have to pay some fees to your accountant
and stuff but it's also very tax
efficient because
for the first i think it's like 11 12
000 pounds that you make
you can pay yourself you pay zero income
tax
and the tax benefits of paying yourself
through a company i'm not a tax advisor
so speak to an accountant
um but it's it's much better than being
a sole trader
generally speaking so i would always
recommend speaking to an accountant
and with the eyes of having a limited
company
for deal sourcing that helps all right
last question
joe the myth says can you use forces
help to buy to get into property with
say a brr
i literally have no money to start
no you cannot help to buy is a big fat
sham generally speaking and help to buy
has got a lot of strings attached to it
so if you want to
be creative if you're wanting to run a
business if you wanted to buy a house
and push the value up and refinance it
these lifetime isis and help to buy
skins they're all set up
for you to buy a house to live in for
you to then pay off the mortgage
um so if you want to do brr
you've got three currencies in life
money
time and knowledge and you're saying to
me i've got no money
but i want to do vrr how can the
government help me
well they're not going to help you you
need to think well i've not got money
but could i get knowledge and do i have
time
if you've got knowledge and time but no
money you can do a brr deal
find a really good deal with the
potential to lift in value
and then you can bring it an investor in
because you've got the time to do the
deal and the knowledge to know where to
look for the investor
so don't look at what you haven't got
look at what you have got
and remember you don't need money to
start a property business
you need time and you need knowledge
and lots of other things like courage
and creativity but not necessarily money
so don't take yourself out the game if
you're watching this channel and you're
inspired and you want to do property
deals but you think you're too old or
you're too young or you haven't got
enough money or whatever it might be
just remember myself and most of my
students started with nothing
and built their portfolios up so i hope
this has been helpful i hope you're
feeling inspired and educated and well
informed
don't forget to drop your comments and
questions below in the comment box
and next week i'll be answering your
questions you can subscribe to the
channel please do subscribe
right over here if you want to watch
more q a sundays you can do so right up
here
and i hope to see you at the property
investors crash course in person
real soon thanks for watching see you
next time